hey everybody and welcome to a
synchronized wild ride with steo I'm
just kidding it's not synchronized it's
juicier than hell I mean nothing is off
limits for Joey fona I was sitting there
this whole episode thinking wow this is
intense I mean we're talking candidly
about what it feels like to get
timberl and how it felt to get ripped
off by the manager who did apparently a
lot worse stuff than just that I mean
it's incredible how open and unflappable
and totally cool Joey faton is so get
ready because this one's amazing let's
get into it ladies and Gentlemen people
of the Universe I bring to you Joey
faton thank you thank you yeah all of
you thank you how's it going uh we met I
want to say it was like
2013 on the set of a steel panther music
videos right pretty much yeah yeah yeah
yeah correct Steel Panther Good Guys
what's that was that uh end of the world
I believe was the video I don't know I
think something about like humping CHS
party in the world they were all they
were doing blow people were topless it
was it wasn't my demographic but it was
definitely interesting yeah yeah and and
and and we we hit it off man like uh
well people were doing blow in the music
video Yeah but I know if it was real or
fake
milk very very very fake okay yeah and
um and so all all these years go by I
mean we exchanged phone numbers that day
we never uh never talked once and then
bumped into each other here on this
cruise ship and uh what a TR here so I
guess being on an Impractical Jokers and
Eric Andre Cruz
like how it's nice well the long story
is short the short story story long as
far as meeting the guys I met them from
doing the show The Jokers so uh from
meeting them in New York and doing a
couple of the skits with them they
actually got me a job I hosted an
Afterparty show for them so it was like
a wrap-up show for The Jokers so then
all of a sudden they're like hey we're
doing this crazy idea to do this cruise
I was like all right what the hell for
the very first season I can't remember
it was like four what six years ago
probably five five or six years ago do
this cruise and every year it's gotten
bigger it's gotten better and better
with I mean the very first one I think
was like Lisa Lampanelli and Gilbert
Godfrey I'm saying with the comedians
that came out and then it just kept Bert
came out year after that we did battle
shots together bur CH stuff so all these
people just started coming out so for
these guys I got kind of wrapped up in
it and they're [__] great guys they
are they're just really good dudes
they're from Staten Island from Brooklyn
so we have a lot of things in common as
far as like the upbringing and stuff
like that with our families it's great
so Vanilla Ice has been to almost every
single Gathering of the jug for ice to
you're like is that amazing you're the
Vanilla Ice of the cruise ship you're
the Vanilla Ice of the Impractical
Jokers it's great man so I mean
obviously like uh you know the the the
first question the only question like
who in which member of insync crushed
the most
beef crushed the most
beef what beef are we talking about cuz
the could go Lance
or yeah um blew the most beef or what
talking sorry no I didn't say beef I I
didn't say beef I said beef be be
be yeah I don't know okay I'd have to
smell everyone's fingers to find out I
have no clue I couldn't even tell you
you know what's so funny it was so back
then your boys are over here poting to
you i' like to let everybody know like
uh Joey brought peut Gallery over here
yeah Joey brought in the biggest uh what
do you call it Entourage Entourage that
we've ever had a guest bring and and it
was great because normally we're in a
van and we can't even fit a publicist so
this is great you brought one two three
and the other one the other one left
yeah he too claustrophobic I asked who
who got the most Beav and all of your
boys pointed to you which was
[__] I wish but you know what I will
say there was a lot of Lobby love going
on and what that meant is there was
always women downstairs in the lobby
hanging out and talking to them and it
was interesting because a lot of us
though not me were younger than what
they could have been doing so obviously
in the boy band realm obviously not that
say that we had people say oh you can't
do that you can't do this but it was
just like okay well we're young we can't
be drinking or being crazy or like that
well how how young were you like I was
17 18 years old when I started Justin
was 14 wow Justin was 14 Lance was 16 me
and JC were 17 started turning 18 and
Chris was the oldest he was 24 and and
what year was was this 95 when we got
together in a group 95 96 oh wow and
then you know years later but then on
tour there was there was a lot of
smelling of the uh vag but not so much
of the and all you guys went into it
single no relationships like everybody
no I already kind of had relationships
here and there I mean went and con I
mean I I was dating I had my
ex-girlfriend who I was with for a long
time we were married got divorced now
obviously but uh it was more of like you
know dating you want to come in can
interview you a clean lady clean
lady so were you guys were you guys torn
around when you were under 18 yeah so
but we were in Germany so obviously a uh
age for drinking was 18 which is nice
but how how were you did you guys have
to sign like a consent over for somebody
kind of chapon you around or uh justus's
mom actually was a chaperon and Lance's
mom had to be happened to be a teacher
High School teacher so she was on the
road with us still tutoring them and
then his mom his Justin's mom was like
the legal guardian for Justin like or
sometimes Justin's mom would leave
Lance's mom would stay but the three of
us we didn't give a [__] cuz we didn't
have any guards and you guys were just
going around on on airplanes buses buses
uh we had one guy who was our wardrobe
our basically our manager our security
and our wardrobe we used to have [__]
wardrobe we used to wear the same
clothes couldn't even wash them half the
time cuz we were traveling so much but
literally was like either a bus or a van
because back in the day obviously there
was no we have any money so during
Germany times about two and a half years
we were out there and slopping it in
bands and a bunch of [__] crazy wow so
1995 you formed but when does it pop off
it started popping off in 97 in Europe
cuz that's when boy bands were big back
then but here 95 96 I ever were dealing
with Pearl Jam Nirvana it's all grunge
nobody gives a [__] about boy bands in
the states so over in Europe Germany was
very popular so it really popped off for
us it was kind of cool because we were
kind of practicing and kind of honing in
on our craft while Backstreet started
being big in Germany but then kind of
when they opened up the door it was like
you know Hansen all those other bands
over in Europe we kind of waled in and
like oh boy bands accepted but then when
it came over to the states it was a
little bit different it was only like
Spice Girls back streen I think Hansen
really started coming in as a as a you
know pop culture music again there were
more of like a flash there right I guess
but it was just one of those things
where it opened up the door for for us
so we didn't have to really struggle
that hard that saying like oh well we
were the first first P but I was like no
people started liking the pop music and
we kind of went in and people like oh
[__] yeah so basically we took up a
Backstreet scraps all the [__] that they
said no to we said yes I love it how big
were the venues um back in the day
Europe they were probably they were open
just venues so people were just packing
in they just be shoving people do a lot
more radio shows but a lot of times it
was maybe maybe 2,300 maybe 5,000 and
then and just started slowly going
bigger like oh we're selling out this
I'm doing theaters and now we're going
to go to the States but it was weird
when it started getting bigger and
bigger it's like what the [__] is going
on really is it's really it's really for
me I don't know why I've just always
been not saying humble but I just always
had my feet on the ground I've never
been like people like goes oh you're
you're you're kind of Average Joe [__] I
go yeah because I'm not going to
[__] you what you see is what you
get there's
no stick even on set when I'm hosting
something you still see my stupid jokes
I'll [__] up stuff I'll say something
stupid but it's just you know I think I
think because I'm just natural and
normal and I'm not trying to be anybody
else and that's what I guess what what
makes my demographic kind of cross the
board over with everybody was it like
the New Kids on the Block where like
people thought you guys were one way and
you guys would get in the fights I
actually looked up to New Kids on the
Block that's that's the group that I
every time when I first started want to
be in a boy band or just singing or
performing I saw them I was like I want
to do that [__] when I'm when I'm older
why can I get a chance to do that and it
was interesting enough that me pursuing
that and going to it and getting to that
and then having these people my peers
and hanging out like boy to just saying
like different people I always looked up
to somebody that you go oh [__] I'd love
to meet that person but now you're
working with them and doing things with
them it's like this is [__] in grade
school that's crazy were there in sync
brawls not really
many got a couple headlocks and face
just over I mean between you guys I mean
like others [__] like jealous boyfriends
of like girls passing out at your shows
and [__] yeah well I mean there's so
many guys that would just want to start
stuff I mean we were at a club one time
and and we I was literally talking to a
whole bunch of women some guy comes up
and he's like trying to be trying to be
cool and stuff he's like hey man I heard
you [__] gay and I'm like okay and
what and then he just looked at me I go
let me ask you something I said you're
talking to me you're not talking to any
of these ladies are you gay I'm just
letting you I'm just asking he's like oh
no I'm not he's trying to be I'm like
dude then once you talk to these ladies
have fun why you [__] with me what am
I doing yeah or so many people just try
to be wise asses or one time it did
happen where me and Justin were sitting
at I don't think I've ever told this
story me and Justin were sitting out a
bar uh it was right after one of our
concerts a couple of us a couple
security there was a bar and this one
guy was sitting down with his girlfriend
so we come up to the bar kind of being
nice and quiet people start to notice
who we are so people start couting
around so now people getting a little
bit pushed so me and Justin are
literally sitting there Justin's having
a beer guy goes to stamp he says Hey
excuse me Justin doesn't hear him he
literally went sorry what and the guy
goes get out of my [__] way and one
of our scur go standing but meanwhile
the guy didn't stand up the guy stood up
he was [__] ginormous and we were
like oh [__] some going to go down he
was trying to be all puff in his chest
cuz of his girl and we're like bro we
didn't even think he like no why you get
the [__] off and then [__] started Happ
security guards started beating the [__]
out of each other people getting thrown
across drinks getting spilled but it's
one of those things where you try not to
be a dick and then just pum people just
[__] yeah they can be asshol yeah
for sure and if if my math is right
you're 1995 until 2002 7 years and the
Beatles were actually together for
exactly seven years crazy right and I
would have a tough time believing that
the Beatles during their seven years
sold 70 million albums back in the time
like that there yeah so like I think
that that means that like per the
numbers objectively you guys were far
bigger than the
Beatles when you're that successful you
got to make big moves like Kelly Slater
for example he made huge moves when he
started started his company outerknown
I'm wearing all outerknown clothes right
now and what's awesome about them is
that they're made from organic and
recycled materials in Fair Trade
factories around the world meaning that
they're totally comfy totally classy
totally awesome clothes that do not
negatively impact the environment or the
people who bring them to your closet
that is outerknown I love Kelly Slater I
love outerknown and clearly he loves me
too because all of my friends and
listeners get
25% off their entire order if they go to
outerknown.com
Divo that's o u t k n o w
n.com Devo and remember to also use the
promo code steo to get that full 25% %
off your order with all of your
outerknown clothes man it's epic it's
good for the world it's good for you and
you got to do it so go to outerknown.com
steo use the promo code steo and let's
get back to
it got of sort of I'll never forget uh
Stephen Tyler said this to me we were at
a concert one time this is after ins you
know we split and do our own thing I
went to go see his con goes hey man when
you guys getting back together again I
don't know I'm G asked Justin he was on
tour whatever he's like dude he goes I'm
not kidding he goes the last time I saw
the girl scream like that when I saw
your show was when I went and saw The
Beatles in 63 or something like that he
saw the concert he goes I've never heard
it that loud before like that and I
never thought it or took it in
perspective like that I really didn't
we're not like oh we're bigger than the
Beatles but it's interesting enough
that's only it's not a very big span
seven years is kind of short and it's
amazing how much and the longevity of us
or just even the group even now just
because it just I don't know I guess boy
bands come back and go you know same
thing with music but now people are like
oh we want to do boy band stuff in ' 9s
music now and like [__] I'll hire my ass
I'll do it right the Beatles aren't
considered a boy band sorry they're band
oh but are they a boy band is that a
certain back in the day I mean that's
the thing they always had the the the
argument you know you even say Boys to
Men were you a boy band no they were a
vocal group that's the same thing with
us but however we do all actually
somewhat play instruments and this
actually one of our shows we played the
song That Thing You Do from that movie
The Tom a movie but it's funny because
no one ever saw it that weit yeah thank
you so we did that and everybody played
instruments people like oh [__] you
actually play I was like yeah but we
more vocal group than anything else and
Justin JC did a lot of the writing yeah
I mean a boy band means like a group of
dudes that just like have millions of
chicks like just just wrenched at the
crotch no but I'm saying like cuz cuz
one of the stats was like some you want
them to and some you
don't but it said it said uh you guys
were the highest grossing boy band but
that's not
considering the
the The Beatles were a group of dudes
who appealed to chicks and as such the
boy band I got you yeah it's weird they
have people always say yeah boy band
vocal group or no we're we're a group
and they I don't know I I think all it's
Man Band now when you get older what
like what what are you going to really
say yeah [__] when you have that such
huge success at a young age like that
and you're raking in all this cash like
you buy stupid [__] yeah do you just go
[__] crazy like well like do you have
people managing your money do you say
I'm I'm over 18 I'm going to do what I
want you know just like anything I think
when people come into money that fast
that have never been into money like
that my family's never come to money
that so my family doesn't know much
about investing I was a middle- class
family from Brooklyn when you got money
you got a paycheck you [__] blew it
you went you took your girl out you did
this or your family and half the time
you only me 100 bucks in your account to
go okay not going to pay my bills so
when I had that money it was just
numbers in a bank account yeah I mean I
knew it of course but I'm like you know
I'm 19 years old going you know Dad I'm
thinking about buying a house I'm
thinking about buying a car and my dad
looks at me and I go what kind of car
you think I should get like I really
don't know how much you know he goes
dude my dad goes you can buy whatever
[__] car you want right now you can't
you honestly can I said really so I
remember like slowly I started buying
purchases and stuff that but then I
bought stuff where I thought you know
again 19 years old I could buy my own
house I want a couch that had every
cushion was different [__] colors
that was custom made I had a Star Wars
room of theater that literally had
bought the house was 250,000 I bought
the house and the theater cost me about
400,000 the theater cost more than the
[__] house but it was like I put my
hand on the handprint and hydraulically
slid open it closed and it had Han Solo
and the Carbonite the Frozen Carbonite I
had the de star with the freaking
projector I had a [__] M it was crazy
it was the stupidest [__] but it was
worth more than my sh but the coolest
[__] but after a while you start buying
[__] and the same way you said one of my
my first accountant was like yeah you're
going to be good your family family is
going to be good this this this but
doesn't really explain everything tax of
just everything back to the back to the
Star Wars theater yeah see you work gay
yes I have a sty of lightsaber on my
face
100% uh I think we were all gay once we
watch Star Wars of course I can um but
now I uh watched the the L prman
documentary like famously like Lou
Pearlman signed the backst street boys
then he signed in sync and like
he worked with a lot yeah he he was a
smart businessman for himself is what I
like to call him right um and and so
like this whole back and forth between
the back sh boys and in sync and he was
just like he was the middle man just
laughing though cuz he what he would do
is he was literally almost push us
against each other put in a friendly way
going oh those guys are doing this game
you should do that oh they're working
out they look better you should work out
more you know so it was that kind of
thing and then funny it always kept us
apart not knowing why and there was a
lot of conversations that when we fin
finally started talking to each other
like oh wait a minute so l perlman's a
six member with you guys you two so we
split in you guys six ways and us six
ways but wait a minute he's also a
manager so he's getting a management fee
but then he's also telling us that he
can make sure to take care of the
lawyers because he has his lawyers but
want to make sure that since he's a
sixth member he's going to secure his
ass and our ass so he was double triple
and fipple in everything wow then he
started a Ponzi scheme he started
telling people you know I got Britney
Spears which he did at one point like
he's I got Britney I got uh Backstreet I
got in sync invest in my company
transcon we'll have you go invest in
this thing it's going to be great blah
blah blah these people are like old
retirees literally giving their money
life savings and they would say what are
we doing oh it's great uh stock is going
up let me show you the printouts get
printouts then when they tried to
collect money they couldn't get a hold
of anybody and it literally was a Ponzi
scheme he stole like billions of dollars
[__] and just ran and you're like why
would you do that when you made a
legitimate business though he
legitimately started making his own real
[__] business and was really making
making money and then he got too damn
greedy which is crazy to me yeah and and
and like by structuring it so that he
was a member of the band and the
management fee and controlling the
lawyers on top of that like he didn't
pay you what you were rightfully
entitled to is that right and then they
were all well everything that we were
doing was uh recuperable that was the
fun part too we thought every time he
was taking out the taking us out the
dinner I'll take you guys to dinner and
we'll go here Peter Luger is going hey
and then all of a sudden the bill
everything's all up there one time the
funniest [__] thing and I remember
that's when I was like wait a minute
something's really [__] up we were I
remember we were shooting the Tearing Up
My Heart video and we were in Miami and
me and Justin's birthday was around this
time around January he's like a I'll buy
you buy a gift like oh cool buy like his
Armani jacket that I saw I was like a
[__] love that that's great oh 250
bucks man for me 17 years old [__] of
[__] was on the [__] recoupable thing
so anything I bought he bought me a
birthday gift but I was paying for it
cuz it was on my recruitable bill Jesus
Christ so I was like all right now there
something [__] wrong here and even
even the record company is like I don't
know what's going on we're giving you
millions of dollars but it's not going
to you it's being split but I'm I'm
hearing getting checks for like 20 grand
30 grand that's it so yeah sounds like
we got [__] sounds like the way that
uh I've heard YouTubers describe Dan
bill zerian um managing
ignite exactly yeah it's just it's it's
just mindboggling I think when things
get to a certain degree or money starts
really coming and and you see a lot of
artists like that I think even Billy
Joel's manager you know kind [__] them
over so much definitely it's crazy
though you just can't there you go when
it comes in that fast and that quick you
can't really or try to establish you
really have to have a handle on it or
know the business and again that's why
we're talking about spending money I
never had that business savvy or invest
or where do I need to [__] put my
money and [__] and now thank the Lord I
do but the point at which your dad says
hey man you can buy any car you want is
that like right when you're like
receiving like the $10,000 check from l
later on no this later on no hell no I
was still living with my parents I was
when we were touring in Germany selling
out places uh venues again like 7 8,000
even 10,000 but selling merchandise
stuff yeah I never saw the numbers and I
was still living at home I was at my
house until I was like Lally I think 19
years old when I finally got my first
house but we were on the group you know
two and a half years three years before
that see but but uh what was the funny
business with the financials going on
around the royalties for the album sales
and ticket sales on the the it was it
was everything across everything and so
uh man was there ever any like like
litigation to get back went through a
whole thing we settled out of court
finally he basically got a small
percentage for like a year and then he
was gone is basically what happened but
all the other money that he had prior to
gone I Just sh when um did uh when did
you get l l Perman out of the mix when
things started going down we went to
when did the lawyer filed out a lawsuit
and then that whole Ponzi scheme started
happening after that lawyer lawsuit
people started digging into to him I'm
just trying to get picture did you did
you still have some of the window up to
2002 to to really do it right and and
get get paid yeah yeah yeah no of course
well that was the thing the minute it
start yeah well that's actually when the
lawsuit happened was right before no
strings attach came out and that was
like our big selling one uh that was the
one that she beat all records it was 1.2
million the first day 2.4 million the
first weekway you had already clear
cleared Lou out of the program yeah Lou
was Lou was was out of so it was good
really could buy any car we got we got
we got [__] for a while but thank God
we didn't get [__] towards the really
the the heightened of the actual career
cuz that would have been yeah good man
I'm glad I didn't know that I'm I'm
really glad to know that um now there
were also some
allegations that Lou Pearlman was like
doing some diddling I think I was too
old for him to didd on my doodle I don't
think he wanted I don't think he wanted
an old Guinea Italian doodle I think
that seriously he was always like he
never look like Hey Joe hey Lou because
I was get say if you're going to get
dled at least Let It Be by a smoke show
like exactly I mean that guy was
hot that man I mean when he told you
that they're working out you should work
out I mean he was working out was
working out he was working on his it was
weird it was weird cuz always always
like did he touch you did he I'm
honestly I'm being I was like no he
never I don't he never like hit on me or
anything every once while be like oh he
hit on me I was like but what did he do
touch you what actually what it actually
and they would never say well he was
just being flirtatious okay but he a
[__] grown ass man you're young it's
kind of [__] weird let's be real here
but okay whatever to each his own that's
why I feel me if you're older age knock
yourself out but it's weird is he still
around no he died died he died in prison
oh wow how long when did he go to prison
oh gosh the pon right after because of
the Ponzi gin yeah he fled the country
where was he do you remember he was in
Germany like somewhere no like istan or
some weird [__]
country basically they saw him eating in
a picture he was outside somewhere and
they were looking for him they found him
they grabbed him were you guys like what
the [__] would have seen fin we were
like where the hell is he no one knew
where he was and when the things start
happen like a he went where Russell
Wilson or is it Russell Wilson the de
Jam guy Russell Simmons Russell Sim yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he went asan too
yeah
Russell Wilson who is there even a
person that no but
there people are Googling Russell Wilson
right now and he's like [__] I don't
know who that is um so so you're going
off it's crazy like just unbelievable
amounts of money because now you're
doing it right and like you had to get
you like you had to have been in
stadiums numbers don't lie especially
not number two and when you're going
number two let me tell you how important
it is to do it the way that God intended
and that is with Squatty Potty this is a
very important thing that goes in front
of your toilet which you put your feet
on to raise up your legs so that you're
in a squatting position the way that God
intended you to poop this is how you get
a complete evacuation and how you avoid
some health risks I'm telling you it's
important and Squatty Potty is the one
product that we promote on this podcast
which I have been using for the longest
time I'm talking about an entire 10
years that this has been helping me poop
completely and healthily and it's time
for you to start if you haven't already
and man they've got a deal for you go to
squattypotty.com
sto and you will NAB 20% off your order
telling you if you're not using it then
it is bad news so one more time go to
squattypotty.com
steo for 20% off your order and start
pooping the way God intended now let's
get back to
it at that time yeah I mean I I bought a
a stupid house that was the dumbest
thing I ever I've loved it I had a 4
acre house that was 10,000 square feet
my master bedroom was 3200 square F feet
the garage was 3200 feet I had like a
man you know freaking whole cavem man in
there Orlando Florida oh yeah I got rid
of that damn house but after a while you
know I love that again being young you
want everything you think oh this is
what I need I need this oh I need a
[__] the car display that had the
turntable and everything I had a night
ride I still have the night ride you
want to have to back out of a garage
right no should turn table but I had a
five car garage with this thing it was
crazy but after a while as I got older
I'm like why do I I'm not even home half
the time or when I had my kid my kid was
on the second floor and I never went up
there never went up there I'm like why
am I doing this after a while so
literally got rid of all that [__] and
finally like my okay let's live to
California for a little bit and then saw
a state tax and said [__] that I'm
moving back to Florida for sure wow
that's great is is there a point where
like youve reached such a success that
that like it's hard you're just
desensitized to to anything at all
because like when you're doing stadiums
and you get that cheer and you get that
like adrenaline rush there's nothing
like it like you know what for me being
an Entertainer I think it doesn't matter
what group or how many it could be 500
people it could be five people could be
5 million cuz and especially with all of
us we've performed in front of less
people or more people but I think it's
just a gratification to get that instant
that instant [__] feel I think you
know when people do films and movies
it's great but you're waiting for that
you don't know if it's funny or not you
don't know if it's going to hit really
unless the audience does it you get that
instant gratification on stage that's
why I love performing I'll tell you you
having like your your little uh sausage
party going on over here like hearing
them laugh when something's fun that
adds so much to the experience yeah
maybe we'll do a live podcast you should
yeah you don't want these [__]
knuckles in the L that's great so so
fast forward a little bit when you okay
you guys are blowing the [__] up when
does the conversation start happening of
in sync really starting to to split and
why does it happen it wasn't it wasn't
even a conversation I think just from
from literally going hard seven years in
a row we were busting our ass for two
and a half years of rehearsing the same
four songs and not doing [__] never got
a record deal until like almost two and
a half years so we started 95 around '
97 is when we start with Germany left
for Germany did all this stuff 9798 99
pretty much 99 came to to the States was
there 2000 200 2001 it was done so but
it was like one of those things where
Lance wanted to do some do do [__]
some being an astronaut in [__] space
he literally got he got certified being
a cosmonaut and everything went to
Russia wouldn't do in the states so he
went to Russia to do it there Justin and
JC started write music together but they
wanted to do kind of their own things
everybody was just kind of just worn out
a little bit we like you let's take a
break so Justin was like I want to write
new music and I think that's where that
went to deter because the record company
was like okay well we see Justin as a
young solo artist now this could be kind
of like a Michael Jackson thing or
whatever the case may be see he said
yeah I didn't mean to well no no like
but it's it's very cliche but yeah but
like the five brothers the one going
away dude so like uh I'm I'm so sorry
I'm trying not to like be so rude but
when you said that I was like because
when Johnny Knoxville started did the
Bad Grandpa thing like like like we
didn't know about it right but um they
uh there there stories came out on the
internet in 2012 of like um you know
Paramount Pictures just bought the
domain names jackass for Jackass 4 movie
Jackass 4 Bad Grandpa like Bad Grandpa
movie like every so we're like oh like
you know like is ah we got a new movie
this is crazy like why why didn't they
tell us why then we find out that
actually knox's making a movie Under the
jackass Banner on his own without us and
like so how's that really Under the
Umbrella right like uh and and I and I
actually like went on to say like dude I
I remember it as like the time when
Knoxville Timber Lake
does that's exactly it that's exact I
think a lot of people have gotten
Knoxville and Timberlake yeah I was like
I was like dude Knoxville Timberlake us
now I'm the jack that we can relate to
something and that's that's something
that we can [__] relate to by getting
duped by our [__] boys right son
[__] but I get it but it's weird
though it really is when you go but how
was that it's weird when you go now I'm
the Jackson
4 Tito blood was there any blad bad
blood after you guys split and Justin
was it was just one of those awkward
moments of like yeah man cool and then
the record company was really pushing
what really was I remember somebody just
said this to me a couple days ago and I
wasn't even thinking about it I was like
and and it made me go back to the
thought of being there and I was like
[__] that's right basically we did the
MTV Awards and Justin was doing his
first performance solo so we were like
okay we thought and he was even saying
after we do this I'm going to do the
tour us will get back together no big
deal but I think and it was weird
because I think the record company kept
pushing kept pushing and they kept
separating us it was kind of weird so we
to go do to Red caret he's not on the
red caret with us just the four of us
like thought he was going to be well he
was going to go I think I think I don't
he was with Britney at the time no it
wasn't with Britney yeah I think it was
post so he started he just went and did
the OWN I like okay whatever we
introduced his performance how [__]
weird is that hey hey guys we're here
here's Dustin
Timberlake it's weird it was like one of
those things that people were like oh
honestly for me I was proud of him
because he again I'm not a writer a big
difference I'm a I'm a team player with
it comes to a lot of that kind of [__] I
don't get so upset like oh man he duped
us he did that I'm like no if that works
it's going to help us out in the long
run for all of us who were able to do
this or do something we're all going to
eat in some way shape or form so it's
like for you bro if you're going to do
that go knock yourself out he blew the
[__] up yeah well check this out and
then you go so what happens now yeah
check this out there's uh I I I made
this crazy video called uh celebrities I
did cocaine with okay I told this like
really like glorious story about Kid
Rock what I what I what I it didn't like
make the story because it wasn't as big
of a deal but like the I met him and all
of this happened in Miami on New Year's
Eve as
2004 turned into 2005 okay and uh as I
was driving down to Miami for this part
was a Paris Hilton party and like it's
New Year's so like on the radio I'm
listening to uh you know they're saying
and for the you know for the 2004 the
highest grossing concert tour was like
Metallica and they gross like this
amount of money and then like uh I'm at
the party and I just see Kid Rock and
I'm like like oh damn this this is kind
of stoked I started talking to him and I
said to him because it was just fresh in
my mind I go man can you believe
Metallica gross like whatever it was
like a hundred million dollar or
something and he here we say that
immediately goes yeah but those [__]
split it four ways like I like I take it
all myself I make way more than that
that's true we yeah it's true though
that's the other thing you know you
split it different ways you're like okay
wait a minute and that's why same thing
with Justin it's like and I and I would
say the same thing let's be real if I
had my own if I did my own brand from
the ground up though afterwards even
though okay we were on you know saying
John I'm just saying you did your own
brand but if you can collaborate great
but if I'm going to make my own brand
don't steal my th it's weird I don't
want to like it's but I'm a team player
I don't get mad at it but I'm like yo
let's do something together let's
collaborate it then you do your own [__]
let's collaborate again right did you
try making or did you try going the solo
route as for yourself yeah but for me
again like I said I'm always Entertainer
so what happened was is after within
sync I started doing uh Broadway I
always wanted to do Broadway so I did
Network this show I ho myself out I did
it all but it's fun that's my that the
thing for me is I love again entertain
but I love the different things and what
was great about me now was like I didn't
need to do it for the money it was is it
fun [__] yes let's do it it's cooking
show I love cooking let's go it's this
let's go you know so for me that's the
nice thing about what I get to do now is
I get to pick and choose the nice thing
about who I do is that I get to pick and
chew yeah dude blur chew it's the blue
chew tablet it's got the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Calis so you
know when I chew it it is on with my
lady and I am going to perform at the
top of my ability that's why I love it
and that's why I think you might love it
and you can get an entire month supply
of Bluetooth tablets completely for free
all you pay is five bucks for shipping
what do you got to lose man you go to
bluechew.com
use the promo code steo consult with the
medical provider right online it's takes
a couple minutes couldn't be easier your
prescriptions taken care of and again an
entire month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets on its way to you all you pay is
five bucks for shipping so if you've
been wondering if you might really enjoy
yourself after a blueooth tablet it's
time to stop wondering and start chewing
yeah dude so one more time go to
bluechew.com use the pr code steo and
enjoy an entire month's supply of
Bluetooth tablets completely for free
just pay five bucks for shipping now
let's get back to
it I mean hey we're on the Joker's
Cruise they ain't [__] paying us [__]
really come on now but we because we
love it it's fun these guys are [__]
great they're good friends of mine so I
I do it anyway for them yeah and you
guys both were on Dancing With the Stars
yeah dude you got on there like your
early adopter Season Two Season Four
Season four close season four well then
wikipedias got you wrong no they got me
wrong it might have been n cliche or
some other [__]
Boyer yeah I I read it as McIntyre might
have did too I think it might have been
Joey McIntyre from new kids okay Drew
did the first don't ask me how I
Wikipedia said that you came in second
place on season two I think I read that
right Second Place season 4 and then I
did the Alum season and got kicked off
the second week oh wow how far did you
make it though I I made it six agonizing
weeks isn't it [__] Gru I was
absolutely the second worst answer but I
was like was masterpie the first I think
masterpie is one of them up there though
Steve wnc was on my good one too why was
it so grueling I mean was it like just
the dance rehearsals was it like that
when you were training for tour but even
well Dancing with Stars was different
because for me we danced but nobody
critiqued us on it so dancing and then
try to have somebody correct your [__]
and tell you you're doing wrong when
usually you're doing things right
dancing wise you're like okay let me
figure this out but I knew my LIF M but
I didn't know posture and frame and all
that [__] my body was hurting ways that
I've never felt before seriously it just
awful but again I think what's cool
about it is is we're talking about
things for me is you know when you have
when you're in a band you're you're in
sync you're not identified as anything
else same thing when you first start
your jackass there's no name really
attached to until you start branching
off and doing your own [__] so when I
started doing my own things it just
helped me with my stuff and like doing
Broadway and then opening up so dancing
with stars one of the things that saw
people saw my personality well yeah I
mean even season 4 you're such an early
adopter that that's the point where
Dancing with the Stars was just like
absolutely like the mest touch for for
Reviving we got a call well I got a call
the first season and I saw the video it
was called Strictly Come Dancing in
Europe they call me up and say hey we
love you to do it I said no does no
nobody wants to see me dance why second
season me and my manager start going
what are the numbers yeah uh about 3 or
four million okay third season we got 10
15 million okay what about the third one
20 do you want to come back 20 and then
we come up and it was like literally 32
million was my I think it was my season
season 4 whatever and it was like it was
one of the biggest ones which was just
cool again but it's so weird how again
when if it ain't broke don't fix it
meaning the show was great before you
see how they started adding more
production value to certain things more
different things which helps it which is
great but the original content the
original thing is the celebrity and the
pro dancing and critiquing that nothing
else I I don't even know how like the
production value changed I just think
that um you know like anything else if
you just Beat It To Death so much it's
just going to get tired it just slowed
down you know it slowed down and and
when you got on it was like really a
vehicle for like brand new and and and
it was like prestigious you know it was
like oh man you got to be on Dancing
With the Stars but like as like they
kind of be influencer Billy you know
like who's that guy I don't know yeah
and it and it started to like show signs
of like being you know the the the
desperate last throws of uh you know
like and it goes in waves to me like
I've watched it a few times and I watch
it obviously but it's always funny cuz I
have watched the first episode a lot of
times of whatever the first season is
cuz you start to watch him and you know
how many people are [__] in their
pants they're freaking out it's
hilarious to watch the nerves of people
that are usually normally confident oh
dude break dude I'm perfectly
comfortable like you know putting
something right up my butt you know like
like but to do a Qui Quick Step but but
to yeah seriously like I mean and and
I'm like so helplessly Caucasian when it
comes to dancing like I mean there's
just no amount who's your who's your
partner I have the same partner as Lance
Bass so you had
a Lac swimmer yeah Lacy's awesome too
but she'll yelled at Hell she'll
probably yelled at [__] she probably
yelled at you about a lot of [__] I mean
you were like it's crazy because we
think of insan as like all all four guys
dancing like perfectly together like in
sync and and uh you it never really
occurs to you that there's uh like a
weak Link in the CH because you guys are
all feel like but in fact there really
was a Le a we a weak link you know and
for you to go on Dancing With the Stars
of course you're going to go in second
place because you actually that was a
strength and my left and my right so I
kept telling them yeah but but Lance was
kind of exposed like like uh as if like
Nikki 6 was going to join like uh you
know big playing bass with the
Stars he was a deer in headlights in
that
sense it is it's it's crazy to see
people like I said you see them break
man on stage like these people like dude
I looked up to you at are like [__]
just they're they're in it any athlete
that does Dancing With the Stars they
because there's it's their Drive they've
been trained that way so they're they're
[__] focuses that way me I was like
if we [__] up let's have fun who cares
who cares was it like that for Broadway
or is that more grueling than with st I
think it's it's grueling because you're
doing eight shows a week and you're
doing it I did it for when I did rent
the first time I did r i did Broadway I
want to do it I had audition they're
like well no you can get the part I go
no no what if I suck so let me audition
so let me show you if I can do it then
you do eight shows a week and I did it
for six months different Dynamic though
because with that you're doing the same
thing it's the repetition so you're not
worried about whether like you're going
to get it right you're so used to doing
it of course get yeah but it's like cir
like but there's not 20 million people
watching and you only have one chance to
do it and it's and it's like a new dance
every week so you're not like you don't
have a routine that you're used to Le
something new every every week you're
learning something new for dancing true
true but the thing is that's what's
scary on Broadway they're not bringing
out a judge of
of like completely crap all over you you
know like they like their job is to make
it entertaining by absolutely tearing
you to
shreds so yeah it's uncomfortable and
like and and the night before the season
premiere I was newly sober so like I it
was like the season premiere was like my
oneye anniversary and um like I remember
I was still living in my little like
dingy halfway house sober living and and
it's the night before the next day is
the live it's going to be 20 million
people watching me on the season the
season premere and I'm like I can't
toilets I can't sleep I'm looking up at
the ceiling in my in my little bedroom
and I'm like like I I I can't do it I
can't do it I got to back out I'm G to
show up and I'm just going to tell them
guys I'm sorry but I quit I just can't
do it and like the the the it was Agony
it was pure hell the agony of how
terrified I was how uncomfortable I was
and and and I can't believe that there
haven't been people that actually did
back out on day one or two I think one
did I can't remember who it was it was
one season that somebody just as they
were about to come in somebody came in
because they backed they freak they [__]
this I'm not doing it that's something
it wasn't on the night before they don't
have all before no that yeah it's just
one of the it's it it's like I said when
when when it's in our when someone
shells his shoes you feel it's a it's
the most nerve-wracking thing when it's
out of your element completely out of
your element and dance with stars is is
one of those things I think for a lot of
people it's just the fact that it's live
20 million people are watching I'm
terrible f up up and even worse even the
worse like when you're newly sober
you're just so emotionally afraid you're
just
like one big exposed nerve it was like
the most like ill-advised thing I
thought it would be safe you know I
thought it'd be safe like oh I don't
know if I should be in entertainment
anymore you know like now like I'm
supposed to live a spiritual life and
deflate my ego like what's being steo
from Jackass going to do like how's it
going to work I'll test it out with
Dancing with the Stars nothing could go
wrong I rehears down the road I don't
have to be
crazy and then all of a sudden wait a
second you know and then it finally hit
yeah no it's it's again it's one of
those eye openers and it's so funny
because so many people have have called
me up and say hey they ask me do dancer
Stars what do you think they a lot I've
had so many other celebrities I'm like
dude just do it what is it going to do
well I don't know my career who gives a
this is not your career dancing you know
what I'm saying but but that's the thing
is that it's a shot in the arm for your
career because it's putting you in front
of millions of people to give you like
uh you know to give you exposure like oh
remind people of it open up my
demographic and dude all of a sudden
like you can't eat at at uh old people's
happy
hour Hond Roa wait what do you call that
like a a happy hour for old people early
bird special early bird special yeah the
Denny's yeah you're get you're getting
mobed by old ladies at the early bird
true cuz one time I saw a family family
legitimately came up the lady was like
the woman was like oh my god do you know
who he is and the kids are like huh he's
from in sync and the Grandma's like no
he did Dancing with the Stars and so it
was like three or four different things
they like no he did the mass singer I
was like okay cool so that's the fun
thing about my career thank God that
it's spanned over so much different
demographics and stuff that I'm still
able to do certain things and so far no
one told me I sucked yet which is good
that no one told me ick how talented is
uh Tom berser on [__] man unbel producer
he was he was the host the host was he
didn't he do America's funny home videos
to he's like the gold standard of a of a
a a host a pinnacle host that gets it he
the underlying tones on things that he
says some things that he say you know
just the delivery on everything is I'm
I'm trust me they should have brought
his ass back he's great I I can't
believe that I didn't Tom we miss you
bro seriously be watching this which
you're probably not yeah what's he doing
now I mean he's cre the Jack Chill I
don't know I mean no no idea but he's
just I consider him like uh he's the
best yeah like Brodney Mullen of
skateboarding
is he's all he is people exactly when
you meet him too you always like okay
this guy a host what the [__] he's he's
great he really is he's just a he gets
it he just gets it I love about him he
impressed upon me early the importance
of daily meditation oh really no good
yeah and then I'm a big fan of of that
um okay so now recently like uh you know
it shocked the world there's a new
insync song for the new trolls yeah
trolls 3 came so like I mean not that we
wouldn't have like wanted to have you on
like at any time but it's just so
exciting that right in this moment like
insync has reared it we came iTunes yeah
in sync is is back and and like uh they
got a new song and there's Rumblings of
a new tour and like and they're like
when and everybody's like we don't know
I mean the thing is though that like
like kid said you know like why split it
four ways in your case with five ways so
like when you can keep all the money
yourself and from the perspective of
like the the label or whatever like the
management like you got to like it's
there's that many more hotel rooms that
many more babysitters that many more so
like it adds up it adds up it adds up I
mean you see back street going out right
now half the time when they go out they
don't got to band yeah why it's cheaper
right I'm just saying just travel and
everything but it it yeah it's what
you're saying I'm sorry job no I mean
just there's there's incentive on on all
sides for if you can get away with one
person doing it then why the hell would
you do five I think I think what it is
is uh as far as us doing for me I can
always speak for myself but I think the
Nostalgia wise of it why not do it um
yeah MoneyWise is would be freaking
amazing it' be crazy just because again
a lot of people haven't seen it we're
the only group I think as far as any boy
band hasn't gotten back together back
Street's done stuff before new kids boys
to like all all these bands like the
Spice Girls Victoria Beckham she
wouldn't do it yeah what wrong with
her stupid my girl loves the Spice Girl
so much like it's like why would you do
it right dude I just remembered that I
have two Justin Timberlake stories oh
God like I was I was gonna I was gonna
uh I was going to ask you like uh if
throughout it all like do you have like
a relationship where you're in touch and
yeah we all talk yeah we still talk of
course yeah I mean it's funny cuz we
still do merch together so our merch
merchandise we still have to go okay do
we approve this we like this shirt are
you guys on a group chat group chat
email everything a dude that's great
okay so I was CED out of my mind in
2006 I remember it then if you out
unbelievable I've got this crazy mem for
dates actually it was specifically Super
Bowl weekend in Miami and I'm pretty
sure it was February of 2007 and you're
probably right yeah Super Bowl is always
in February I'm pretty sure it was 2007
um I think it's the day after the Super
Bowl I'm still awake we're at this hotel
in uh on South Beach um I'm with this
chick we're having like breakfast or
lunch or brunch with Johnny Knoxville
I'm just
so on coke that he's like literally just
putting Xanax bars in My Soup not trying
to hide it he's just dropping in the
soup and I just scoop that that bar with
my spoon and you know like down go the
Dan SPS but it doesn't even bring me
down I'm like like King Kong and you
shoot him with a dart and he doesn't
even care and like I got to take a leak
and so I'm like going to go like kind of
look like over by the pool to like uh or
whatever to like go pee in some bushes
or something and here's Justin
Timberlake walks right now mind you
Justin Timberlake he didn't perform that
Super Bowl that Super Bowl was performed
by Prince okay that's what it rained
that's it rained on Prince because it
very very now Justin Timberlake walks by
I go dude cuz cuz I've seen the Super
Bowl the day before I'm still awake
Prince performed the halftime show he
totally got rained on and I had major
beef with Prince because I had met him
and he was like super addict to me same
same super adct to
me Prince was such a dick to me so I
stopped just in Timberlake and I'm like
dude it gave me so much joy to watch
prince get his ass rained on and I just
like one want you to know that I am
keenly aware or however I put it like
like his dancing is just so pathetic
compared to yours and I'm glad he got
rained on you know and JT's like okay
that kind of okay and and I'm like I'm
GNA take a leak and and and he's got
this like super fancy like exclusive
Bungalow like like his his Bungalow and
he's like oh you want to take a leak
he's like dude come on in here but I got
to go like he walks off I just he walks
off leaving
me in his Bungalow all of his stuff
there I swear I looked around I was like
like I I could just Rob everything in
this room like I could just like he's
out of his mind how did he just let me
in here oh just make sure you close the
door when you leave buddy I got to go
what a give her yeah God what an
absolute lunatic no you brushed his
teeth and your balls
like R you should have shove his to up
your ass I would have great yeah but but
I I didn't I was I was I was super
respectful I I I I peed I peed I left I
closed the
door yeah prin is an [__] by the way
yeah let's talk about Prince being a
jerk what was your what what happened to
you I I I this thing like I I you know I
graduated from clown college I like had
I'm a prolific performer of Bart tricks
I had this one like standout bar trick
that was above all my other ones I have
a cup of uh like the cup of liquid
whatever I need here's this cup I'm
going to balance it on my head when I
let go you know I'm going to let go I'm
going to put my arms down by my side and
while I balance this drink on my head
I'm not allowed to raise my arms and I
have to drink it without spilling a
single drop you know and it would be
like if I can do that would it be worth
a free drink and of course it is so this
is how I used to get free drinks
whenever I would see celebrities I would
find the cup and perform it for him so
I'm with this chick and I was at the
time I was dating like a Sports
Illustrated swimsuit model you know nice
this this famous you know model from
Denmark and Prince is like talking to
her you know because she's like a Sports
Illustrated swimsuit model and like and
I'm performing my trick for Prince so
I'm now IM balancing I lay down on the
ground I pick up my knees and with my
knees I pick the drink up off my head
put it on the ground pick it up and
drink it and while I'm performing the
trick Prince turns to my chick the model
and he goes does this impress you like
just like such like the most dickheaded
and she goes and she goes yeah it's
actually pretty impressive you should
check it out you know and like and uh
and he just kind of scoffs at it like
like oh you know and he was just like
overall just an absolute you know I
don't know if he golf clapped me when I
was done or whatever but it was just
like he was intentionally as disrespect
respectful to me as he could have
possibly been that's my take I don't
understand why certain people like that
and he was one of them we had a party
right after an MTV award show in New
York this was the year that I believe I
watched Danny badui get thrown on his
face by what's her face uh uh the
wrestler China China okay when she had
that Wonder Woman outfit on whatever it
was I remember why I remember that [__]
cuz she had big boobs
um Club call twist party was Nelly and
ins syins After Party official after
party every in that place is a celebrity
there's no people that came in or this
and that some producers people
everybody's celebrity back in the day it
was a wind up camera so I'm taking
pictures with Lisa left ey Timberlin
bust a r oh [__] yeah up in this second
area this VIP area where where in Sy is
and a couple other people is Prince like
[__] Prince is here at the [__] party
let me go up there go up there I'm
watching he's talking to somebody I'm on
a balcony looking down at people there's
nobody really up here he's talking he's
talking the person walks away I go great
now's my time to talk to him I go hey
Prince you know Joey goes I know you're
okay man you mind if I take a picture he
goes no I rather not and turns around
just like that but turns around as if to
talk to somebody and there was nobody
there so he went yeah I rather
not
wow and looked around I was like this
[__] I was like are you serious
like you know who yeah Joe I know you
are congratulations great you want me
take a picture no I rather not I'm good
oh man I'm I'm
I'm yeah I'm totally debating like
whether or not I should reveal
that like what you described like almost
forb when it wasn't to me I just
witnessed it happened like uh was my
second JT encounter
St what it was was we were we were
should have [__] said I hate that we
we were in some like uh I don't know
exotic locations maybe International I
can't remember where I believe it was
during shooting wild boys and it was
just random that like that uh uh you
know here's I think I think he was with
Cameron Diaz at the time and um so maybe
it's a little bit more permissible
because he's like with the lady and like
kind of like yeah but if he knows who
you are it wasn't it wasn't me and it
wasn't it was it it was a member of the
crew gotcha but still it might have been
shaa I think it might have been shaa
zablo and um and and I think he was like
oh hey like uh I think it was like she
like oh hey Justin like uh I I hate to
bother you but I'm a big fan like I'd
love to get a picture and he's like oh
you don't want to bother me like don't
do
it I love when people go they go I hate
to be an [__] I'm like too late you
are yeah like I don't mean to interrupt
you oh wow that's interesting what is
the
plan but for me it's I've always been I
don't know for me I've always been if
unless I'm doing something I will stop
and take a picture like one time I was
literally at a theme park argument my
wife and somebody came up like yo not
right now are you serious yeah like I'm
sorry I don't me to be rude but I'm
[__] arguing with somebody what about
while you're eating hate that
tooy I mean there always a time in place
for everything and I get it you want to
do that wait after or if you can't wait
that long to [__] I mean I had we were
at Habachi Place one time and it was my
whole family sitting with me and then
there was another family on the other
side so as one woman literally comes up
and says hey uh my daughter's
recognizing you do mind if I take a
picture I said yes not a problem here's
the deal when you guys are done with
your dinner since people I even [__]
explain it to them once you're done with
the dinner tell me when want to see you
guys done I will walk outside with you
and take the picture just because I
don't want anybody won't bother I'll
quietly walk out with no problem yeah as
the dinner is still going on with them
we just sit there and start ordering the
girls are taking pictures across the
whole time flash goes off she I'm like
they're taking pictures while she even
asked I said yeah after we're done I'd
be more than happy to take a picture
talking to my family hanging out finally
lady comes back up she's a little drunk
now she comes up she goes hey can we
take that picture now I said ma'am I've
never really been rude I said but you
asked me to take that picture I go yeah
and I said I would take it after right
yes well why are you daughter taking
pictures the whole time we were sitting
there she goes no they weren't I go let
me see their phone goes I'm not going to
let them show you my phone I well then
I'm not going to take the picture I'm
sorry have a good day just like that two
seconds later I get smack at the back of
my [__] head my mom goes you get the
[__] out there right now and take that
photo and went okay cuz my mom was right
back there and she was like you go out
there right now and I was like but she
was rude they would take a bit how old
were you 30 pretty
much l SP like 29 30 d That's F I wish I
had
Italian oh dude she'd smacked the [__]
out I get the shoe she picked it up
literally right in front like what is
your problem there are the reason why
you're here you go and say hi to them I
go I get it Mom but I'm taking a [__] so
no you do right and then then you go
outside and the lady pulls a prince on
you and she turns away
correctly exactly but it's weird because
people but again when you do that
there's always a time and a place we say
but then there's always people that just
take it to that next level that you're
like come on I mean we get it we're all
here we're having fun because like one
time speaking of Justin me and Justin
were at just not too long ago he
happened to be in Orlando we went to a
bar we're hanging out woman comes up and
we're having just just a deep
conversation about so we're outside
Nobody's around she wases hey do mind
take a picture you know what yeah sure
no take we take the picture she goes
back in two minutes later we bring five
or six people oh my niece and my aunt my
cousin I said ma'am I said we just took
the picture we're actually having a
conversation is it okay that we don't
take this picture we took one for you
well that's rude how is that rude we're
in a conversation I took a picture with
one person but now you want come on what
is yeah that's what good show on
TZ public domain someone told me I was
public domain really kind of he's public
domain we we need him you can come out
and say do whatever you want that's I
I'm like you like I'm you know I I kind
of go through phases of it like uh I'm
generally really really good the only
thing is that there's a certain point
like I don't know if it's around like 30
take a photo and counters like maybe 50
take but but I absolutely have like a c
off point where where I just can't like
joyfully participate in an encounter
anymore and it's nothing like and it's
not even really their fault or just it's
nobody's fault it's ABS perfectly normal
people but I go up from like can oh can
I get a photo absolutely we can't like
oh my God like really like you know and
and uh you know I put effort into but up
to a certain point when I've had just so
many encounters like I just don't have
like give me the [__] phone well
that's the thing they hey can we take a
photo yes or sometimes I'll yell at
people as they're taking do me a favor
get your camera ready so just so you
don't because the minute they go to get
oh I got a flip no I can't do oh let me
hold or you could take the picture
delete photos cuz I'm at you know I'm
out of iCloud store people just get
ready just get your photo cameras ready
that's all we ask it Lees the selfie
don't stop and go oh hey will you take
this picture and then hand your phone to
the guy who doesn't know how it works or
they up when they do the group photo and
they want everybody's phone to be send
it to everybody air dropping what is
wrong with you but hey you know what I
agree with your mom man we are so
fortunate dude I'll never forget I
probably told the story before but uh
like right when jackass came out um the
the first spring break it would would
have been March of 2001 and I'm at the
largest nightclub in the USA it's called
Club lavila in Panama City Florida and
like 2001 they didn't have cell phones
with cameras they had already had the
wind up cardboard disposable camera and
literally everybody had the wind up
disposable car or what if they when they
went to go wind it up wind it up they
didn't do the Flash let me do it again
yeah right but everybody had those and
like I was this is my first experience
being like a in a mass crowd situation
it's spring break you know like it's my
first time being amongst energy right
there and spring break is could not have
been more like purely the MTV
demographic so like I am a pigeon I I am
a loaf of bread in a pigeon group just
like and uh and and and there was this
VIP bar like uh what was going on there
as well that weekend me doing a personal
appearance and the final ever uh
wrestling event for WCW before they got
bought up by the WWE and there's this
wrestler like sitting at the bar in the
VIP you know this huge guy his his
wrestling name was Canyon okay and I sit
down and I'm like a I'm just I'm just
like so like at my wits end I'm so
frustrated I sit down next J and and I
can finally kind of relax and I just
turn to him I go dude one more picture
one more autograph I am going to snap ah
I'm just so and and he looks at me go he
shakes his head he's just looking at me
with the kind of disgust he says hey
man stop and think
about a moment where nobody ever wants
another picture or autograph imagine
you know and I like and I thought like o
like I don't want
thatly say this get annoying when you
take a picture I said no the minute you
stop asking me that's when I'm out of a
job that's what I said too I'm out of a
if you don't know who the [__] I am I'm
not doing my job yeah crowds like like
too big of a crowd unmanageable like
that's there's a certain there's a
certain point you can't accommodate and
like too many like in one day like
there's a certain point I don't have any
in me and it's amazing when it's that
many people how it how it escalates oh
dude it's so funny that's what so weird
to see the people get excited and get
and it just builds up to where it gets
to anger them you're like what is this
going on dud it's so funny like not I
don't know about like Beatles frenzies
but like Scott Randolph and I like we
were laughing so hard um in Australia
because I made the connection that like
like when one person notices you and
then like it's like a chain reaction
everybody notices you and they all turn
into zombies like The Walking Dead
they're just like
yeah they even kind of walk like that
like they're creeping you know like it's
just like oh dude the zombies are after
me dude it's it's like a Walmart in
Oklahoma like it just starts [__] on
Black Friday yeah totally like at the
time The Walking Dead was like the
biggest show onto so we were just
howling about it because every time we
looked at like yep zombies they just
turned into brain eaters hey but we love
you fans we love it love it man and like
and this I'm I'm not go onto a whole
diet tribe on this but we watch
near-death experience videos and people
talking about their life review where
you experience your whole life from like
you actually have the same experience
that you feel the feelings that you made
everybody feel right and so everyone
everyone of these little insignificant
encounters at this point I'm at like the
highest level of like I want to bring
the maximum amount of joy that I
possibly can to each person because I
know I'm going to experience that same
like uh In My Life review same same and
because I've been so like hyper obsessed
about the idea of the Life review and
and and you know I'm going to have the
experience of everybody who I had an
impact on so every little encounter
every person is like the biggest
priority for me and by behaving that way
like it just brings it it it like
changes the tide of like the universe
where like things just start working out
you know like I'm I've eaten every meal
in the like general population Mass food
buffet like taking as many pictures as
possible like and I don't know I'm
having the time in my life so what's
great is you notice that when you do
that out of the gate when you blast it
out though they kind of leave you alone
because they see you all like I'm saying
like every time I've been on the cruise
every time out of the gate crazy no they
don't maybe because I'm just a regular
I've been on it the first time you're
doing it so that's probably why no they
never leave you alone like hey let's get
another
Moto why you took about 80 of them why
why the love of God d man what what else
I I want to tell you Joey that I knew I
was a fan of you and like I knew that
that we were going to have a wildly
entertaining conversation I was not
prepared for how much I was going to
enjoy oh no [__] man I did like really
and and we could talk for hours bro
seriously when when whenever I've met
you like just a couple times but uh
particularly on this ship because it's
more you know recent of course but you
just have this like un flappable like oh
yeah like I can imagine like you finding
out like there's some terrible news and
being
like okay I am no it's true saying that
no [__] and my mom my mom St be Deb
down for I'm just saying like she got
diagnosed breast cancer then she was she
was good you know I her didn't do like
like chemo but then she had to get a
test again she was freaking out like why
you freaking out mom she goes well what
if I have to go but do you have you
don't even know yet if you have it then
cry scream kick the [__] do whatever
you want but you don't know yet so shut
the [__] up stop it life is too short to
worry about things that are beyond your
control right that's the that's for me
that's that's my way of life and that
kind of stuff I always try to look at
the bright side of things obviously
there are dark there are things that
happen in our lives but you always got
to look positive and the same thing for
you when you start to have that outcome
positive Believe It or Not sounds
[__] cliche and shitty but positive
things start happening things start just
rolling you're like oh [__] okay I get
it now it's like what you put in like
and get out like the you know the
universe just begins to conspire in your
favor she put DNA way and spray it
someone's going to get pregnant exactly
you baby from
it I really think that you're the
epitome of don't sweat the small stuff
correct and even the big stuffs it's not
going to matter in 100 years [__]
exactly no one's no one's going to [__]
about me and about another probably 50
60 years [__] for sure um my sources
have told me that you have a tour with
AJ coming up in March I do uh is that
true that is 100% true we did like a
small little tour like an idea we did it
for a '90s uh kind of show in in Tampa
and people loved it so much we did a
small theater we sang each other's songs
made jokes [__] around we had a wheel
where it was just different songs sing
each other's songs so AG is a back
street boy he yes so he would sing ins
stuff I would sing his back keep that to
myself don't tell anybody you know that
don't tell anybody you know that [__]
but yeah so we started doing and we we
we put it up on sale we did East Coast
West Coast a little bit of South and
they sold out within a week it's been
great you know it's nothing huge but
just theater
venues get tickets uh uh Ticket Master
uh Spotify they can go on uh AJ and Joey
and the letter N AJ if I'm not mistaken
I got to double check that but it's Joey
and and AJ the letter who was it that
told us about StubHub we
were the the guy that we uh oh yeah yeah
the guy from the guyub is uh not like
particularly good for the the artist or
the promoter oh really I don't know we
found this out like what what what's and
this is a dick move like this is just
like a uh what do you call it sabotaging
someone's business model but I'm I'm
helping people out by by doing this true
um apparently I'm told allegedly StubHub
like invests um in uh in in op search
search engine optimization so that like
if you're going to Google Joey Fon and
AJ the top of the list is going to be
StubHub get your tickets to AJ and and
Joey um however um
they buy out all the tis they they're
scalpers it's scalp so they buy the they
they they're just scalpers bu they buy
the tickets and then they they they they
resell them for a a like disgustingly
inflated price like you're paying way
more we try to avoid that stuff we're
trying to that but because they spend
the money on the optimization they're
the first thing on the Google thing so
they get the most clicks and so more
people are buying from StubHub and
they're paying way more than they should
and none of it's going to Jo oh yeah
before that back in the day not mention
any groups and bands but old groups and
bands back in the day would scalp their
own tickets obviously there was no
Ticket Master no stuff but they would
scalp their own tickets to make their
own money so the person would buy the
front row and then he'd have somebody go
out I'll give you for 1,000 bucks 500
for first seat 200 bucks not even it's
it's their tickets yeah illegal wasn't
SC like people were like Val you can but
scalping you know you can't back up the
price I mean you sell a
ticket you're chopping the [__] out of
it but it's it's one of those things
where yeah I mean it depends but it's
weird how back in the day and again
that's why I think that's what stub's
doing but it was artists some or certain
artists were doing that yeah and if I
got that R I got it that wrong
completely I'm sorry StubHub I know
nothing but is that I mean StubHub the
same thing as Ticket Master or I would
assume it is though I mean you're just
getting it from anything I mean but for
Ticket Master of Spotify I mean what we
did I believe it's like we put them on
sale for for Ticket Master first so
people get a first chance if they if
they're signed on a Ticket Master same
thing with Spotify if you're signed on
the next day the tickets went after and
then next on Spotify too yeah now you
can do that yeah yeah it's crazy too cuz
on YouTube I I was watching a Jethro
tall music video tell your the concert
the tickets for sale and then in your
region like that's [__] wild it's
wild it's crazy computers are taking
over the world but you can't do with
comedy you can only do with music right
now really yeah cuz I was I was like man
this is great we should try get like
some of Steve's YouTube content where it
shows up and they're like we're only
doing it with musics yeah I think
they'll grow hey uh we want to let you
go but I can't before I give a special
treat to the audience um among my Wild
Ride crew we have a musician and it's
the gorgeous Paul brisy and he's just
been patiently over here camera and I
just know that he's got great stuff to
ask he's going to give you a back
massage I'm going to recuse myself
everybody the gorgeous Paul brisy oh
thanks hey Paul how you doing what's up
Joey how are you I'm fantastic pressure
Paul no pressure yeah that is a lot of
pressure I was just sitting over here
wondering like um it's not even
necessarily a music question but when
Instinct broke up or kind of just
stopped touring together like and then
it became clearer and clearer like oh
maybe we're not getting together at all
like was there a day where it's like oh
[__] it's over and did you have any sort
of identity crisis in that time the yeah
goad was there more to that I think the
day that it actually one of the days was
like Hey I'm going to do my own thing I
think it was one of I think it was uh I
think think I can't remember what year
since you're so damn good at years on
that I suck it was the last challenge
for the children Miami
2001 probably was 2001 2002 something
like that anyway it's when we actually
had a conversation about it and it was
like listen man I think I'm going to do
my solo I don't know if we're going to
do this anymore I think we're pretty
much done I was like well [__] okay now
what literally my brain went to now what
Meanwhile we're do still doing stuff I
didn't think but it's it's going to
fizzle out so I was like [__] what do I
do felt heart broken a little bit felt
betrayed you're young as hell so you
don't know what the hell but I'm
thoughted to think and I literally was
like now I get the chance to do the
things I never got a chance to do before
and I'm saying that's what led to me
doing Broadway led to me doing I've
always been a theater kid me my my
stuff's always been theater so to do
obviously with ins sick and everything
my Pinnacle was doing Broadway so that's
for me my thing I never was really like
oh I'm bummed out that's it my life is
over yeah yeah but some people go
through that which is amaz again that's
why for some reason I've always felt my
feet were always on the ground like
oddly enough I think it helped me being
no [__] famous at an old a younger
age and the reason why is cuz then when
I got back home everything humbled
myself a little bit like for instance
even though I had money at a house my me
and my my future wife at that time well
we were living together we just had a
kid and it was like when I got home it
was like all right now you're doing
laundry write a check I was like I
didn't know how to write checks cuz I
was still young I know how to do a lot
of things so I started doing things in
my house and being what are you saying
you [__]
he still doesn't shut up okay I still
don't all right Che I just Ed I just use
a debit card but yeah it was like one of
those things where I never felt like I
felt of course it was like holy [__] now
what I mean it was we were in our height
of our career we're not doing anything
now like how is that even why are we not
was my thought right right well you're
like part of this group so much like my
life it's like who am I without insync
and were you like hey guys this is Joey
from insync was there a moment where
it's like guys like Jo forone like they
don't have to say from in sync anymore
you know what it never really bothered
me certain times it does when they're
throwing it down someone's throat do you
know what I'm saying like if they're
trying to promot into like hey guess
what guys don't say bye byebye but act
now and you can go to chuckecheese and
see Joey V it's like don't say bye bye
bye you can say chuckecheese just don't
say bye bye bye because it was always
like okay come on but it never really it
still and the funny part is as I've
gotten older and things that I've done
have now made my own name but yeah there
so many times it's hey you remember that
guy Joey Joey from who but now it's
either Joey Fon from ins sync that it's
either Joey Fon from Jokers or we've
seen that guy do dance it's it's
interesting like I said earlier the
demographic has spread so much that it's
so many different genres of different
people that know me from Big F R wedding
movie and [__] yeah I was going to say
that but I feel like that was the first
time I was like oh wow this dude's like
doing his own thingu do some [__] yeah
exactly no we were shooting that
actually when we I was with ins sync
there was uh it was a movie we're going
to do with playtone with Tom Hanks
company playone right after they did
that thing you do that was a name that
was a that was a movie I said something
else yes you said Can't Hardly Wait yep
it's called that thing you do after he
did that film he wanted to do almost
like a Beatles Help movie with us and we
kept saying maybe we should do something
like a Greece and we'll get Britney and
this now this like again the height of
our career never agreed went back and
forth went back and forth I went to the
office to play tone just to say hi to
them and Gary gsman who's one of the uh
one of Tom's uh producers on the shows
and all the stuff that he does I go hey
there's an audition that they're casting
right now for a movie called My Big Fat
Greek Wedding there's a friend of mine
that was in the office she goes you'd be
probably perfect then it'd be right
around the schedule it's a $5 million
budget movie they do the audition go in
I went okay so I went in I read the
lines Nia knew who I was but the casting
L I like he's a [__] singer he's a
boy band it's like glitter he can't sing
so I went an audition and I got the part
and I'm going to call out Paul because
he said dude he was hilarious in My Big
Fat Greek way he's great my family
always did to like Hey we're going to
kill you like that line like we love
that said that line 80 million times
that [__] was not funny in my head
I have a question for Paul and you if if
so Paul's doing music and uh before he
blows up what's the best route for him
to get like a manager so he doesn't get
[__] or he has a a a partner that he's
with like what are some of the pitfalls
that he can avoid to not get SC it's
[__] tough I'll tell you why the only
reason why is because my manager uh has
been working with me since I've known
him since I was 17 me and him work
together at Universal wow he has been
very business on certain things worked
for the uh NBA for this whole freaking
halftime thing he used to do and then
started touring with us within sync my
guys hired him because they knew he's
like a good tour manager so he became
tour manager assistant then as he got
older he's like hey man I'm going to
start managing people I'll manad at you
and the weird thing I'm just saying
because we've had such a longevity
together it's interesting for me to see
other people with their managers and
their people where like me and him are
so open with [__] people are afraid to
tell their artist don't do that or it's
going to do this or you know that's I
like that that's great what the [__] is
he doing I'm like no no tell me
everything it's hard to find somebody
that's what you have to find someone
that's going to give you straight up
honesty not to say he's going to
persuade you to do what what that person
wants to do but give you that hey here's
the option here's what's going on this
is what's good you did a great job in
that but this [__] sucked ass yeah yeah
so if my manager Joe would be here he'd
be [__] ripping [__] left and right
on stuff sometime like hey that sounds
great but don't do that song ever again
I'm like why I like that song he goes
Nobody liked it so we we feed off each
other get get that honesty is what
really needs to happen nice it can be
from anywhere but for me personally my
[__]
started if we would have done that if we
would have flushed the toilet during the
podcast you would have been [__] so
pissed
dude I I I thought the same thing
exactly when I hit BL sit down
here oh man seems like Paul come in AKA
I gotta pee
yeah PA's got a
question right that's true that is true
but uh but you know I'm working on being
more laid-back and and and a cooler guy
trying to be like Joey yeah big time man
I'm really working towards I'm trying I
aspire to being more like you I don't
know if you want to do that I that go
that far but no again man it's just
life's too [__] short yeah it is
think about I always think about this
way we've always talked about people
talked about how you only have so many
Christmases now when you were young yet
had so many Christmases ahead Hanukkah
whatever the [__] you deal with right
but now that shorter and shorter how
many Christmas do I really have left now
I'm 46 I'll be 47 on [__]
Sunday maybe another 40 maybe another 50
I'm not going to be 90 [__] that I'll
probably be 80 by the time I'm dead so
another 40 40 Christmases maybe that's
true as a kid it feels like you have
Infinity Christmases wow you guys said
something earlier too you're like don't
sweat the small stuff that's the key but
if you think about it's all small stuff
nothing is actually big yeah nothing's
going to matter in a 100 years yeah
yeah pass like check it out dude like
with Joey faton absolutely nothing has
been off limits not one damn thing it's
just so much F all the juicy stuff that
we could possibly think to ask you I
think we've asked yeah there's no well
again it's just it's it's my my [__] is
really kind of an open like book in the
sense of like when people ask me yeah
I'll tell you it's just like it is what
it is you know and and and and like
maybe this is just super like ego ego
crazy but I'm feeling like man I feel
like we asked like juicier questions and
we were just like screw it like we just
had the balls to be like what's up with
getting timberl go for it I've had one
time I Howard Tell Me Howard st came up
the first time I did interview he's like
so uh what is Timberlake fingers smell
like that's the first thing he said to
me strong question strong very yeah but
but hopefully you said like let me give
you something real to whiff
on
you don't want to smell that that's been
to the
ringer Timberlake's fingers you kidding
me I'm like a a school cafeteria of fish
fingers over
here lunch lady
fingers yeah dude well [__] man um I
think I got a belly flop contest in 5
minutes I that's that time FES when
you're [__] having fun Sho [__] I
swear to god dude the universe is just
looking out for me man I got I lit it's
about to go [__] downhill if we go
anymore I'm hosting the the belly flop
contest on the cruise ship right now so
dude I love you man thank you so much
come thank you brother you good night
everybody thank you peut Gallery man God
we got to stop doing this [__] in a
van dude it was so hilarious how we
bought bolted out of this room on the
cruise ship and just ran towards the
pool making sure to go right through the
buffet grabbing just plates and plates
of cake I grabbed as much cake as I
could hold Joey grabbed a bunch of extra
cake so he's stuffing it in my face
while I'm running to the pool it was
just the most ridiculous scene man I
fell in love with Joey Fon so much and
uh I I do believe that we have done
what's called a double upload today so
you get to see no no no no that's next
week yeah that's next week ah next week
next week is the the Vlog of the whole
Cru ship experience and mind you next
week is also episode 200 and I have
spilled uh some beans about that in my
Reddit Forum which uh grew pretty
substantially um yeah so if you're not
in the redit the steo RIT get in there
and and actually you know what do
whatever you want because I you can do
no wrong I love you you're my street
team and so I want you just do whatever
you feel like and thank you because I
love you
yeah all
right